[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on adore luigi's mansion 2 semaines que
je fais partie de l'équipe de tmp les
gars merci merci merci merci pour votre
accueil parce qu'on les connaisse pas
parce que vous êtes là mais vous êtes
tous hyper sympa c'est vrai raymond
hyper sympa valérie persyn paisa hyper
sympa gilles merci voilà merci merci
pour l'accueil en tout cas on m'a dit
oui dit il faut que tu fasses un
classique dans tpm p
la tarte à la crème oui moi vivant
jamais de ma vie j'ai ri entarté mes
collègues tu le fais tu l'a pas fait
après on m'a dit bah c'est soit toi qui
prends les tartes dans la gueule soit
sinon tu vas les entarté du coup j'ai
envoyé un mail un peu à tout le monde
pour dire voilà on va changer les badges
à l'accueil s'il vous plaît merci de
passer pour être sûr que ça marche et
avant de piéger les chroniqueurs on a
d'abord testé sur les gens de l'équipe
regardez toutes les équipes de
production leur a fait le coup de la
tarte à la crème on sait que vous adorez
regardez c'est parti il faut les fourbes
[Musique]
et du coup
je fais vraiment mais fait les tirs
personnes me
[Musique]
il
j'te déteste c'est horrible ce tirage
[Musique]
c'est pas toi mais j'ai pas
oh
ok
tous
[Musique]
c'est très drôle ça dans
celui-ci 15
en fait juste revenir sur le faite vous
passez vous trouvez ça tout ça va on
attendait oui c'est vrai qu'ils voient
là on est là mais je les adore regarder
voilà c'est le moment je me suis dit on
a fait les équipes
maintenant on s'occupe de ceux qui le
méritent le plus méconnu coeur merci à
vous alors vous avez fait pareil que
c'est quoi le scénario pour les faire
venir
c'est pareil on a demandé voilà moi je
venais d'arriver on leur a dit ce serait
sympa si vous pouvez venir tourner un
petit truc avec luigi une petite vidéo
et ça m'a touché parce qu'ils sont tous
venus
bah merci à visiter la haine me suis dit
mais ils voudront plus jamais retourné
de sow qui inquiétait pas assez d amour
allez on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
aussi on remballe face à un pack
visiteur
juste pour ça
[Musique]
belle justice
un seul
[Applaudissements]
j'avais fait étrange en effet union
s'est jamais tu vas voir cette offre
c'est plus d'informations
tout
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]